les Bleus s'entend demi-finales de la
Coupe du Monde victoire de business
contre l'Angleterre c'était un match
incroyable peut-être pas le plus beau
techniquement mais avec du suspense
Olivier Giroud a surgi Harry Kane a
complètement craqué et les Bleus ont
donc décroché leur billet pour les
demi-finales on est heureux non
franchement non
on commence presque à s'habituer non
mais c'est vrai
on difficulté parce qu'il faut les dire
qu'ils sont énormément souffert face à
cette équipe anglaise ils arrivent à
gagner à dérouler et nous amener en
demi-finale donc c'est c'est les bonheur
incroyable
chroniqueuse foot sur RTL notamment dans
fait le match merci d'être ici à 110
c'est une journaliste aux Figaro merci
d'être là Augustin Mario Le Figaro live
on est tous ensemble en débrie vous
n'hésitez pas bravo les Bleus nous dit
Mélanie du Québec Virginia l'élégante
Allez la France voilà yen nous dit
Mélanie encore magnifique bravo la
France nous Divonne vous n'hésitez pas
le Figaro.fr YouTube on est ensemble
pendant une petite Vincent roseron sur
place vous avez vécu un grand moment ce
que vous avez serré les fesses qu'en
réalité il s'est présenté pour tirer ce
penalty je suis sûr que vous avez sauté
sur votre sur votre petit siège dans ce
stade au Qatar
alors il est possible que j'ai taper un
peu fort sur la table quand la quand la
balle de la dernière il est parti
au-dessus du but il avait déjà marqué en
plus le penalty d'avance on s'est dit
ouh là là ça sent pas très bon et
effectivement ça y est il a mis
au-dessus et là ça a été vraiment un bon
soulagement et après il a fallu encore
souffrir les quelques minutes qui
restent lors de ce match oui bien sûr
bon on va on va revenir vers vous très
vite pour vous nous raconter tout ça
d'Artagnan il porte bien son nom écoutez
ce qu'il n'est Jeanne d'Arc Napoléon
Bonaparte et l'affront du brexit venger
oui peut-être tout ça en effet peut-être
Augustin
j'ai Vincent heureusement dans l'oreille
qui parle j'arrive Vincent et j'entends
qu'il parle d'Olivier Giraud lui aussi
Augustin alors ce match incroyable quand
même et puis je viens de penser à
quelque chose mais il y a une part de
destin phénoménale quand on sait que
Giroud s'apprêtait à sortir à peu près
10 minutes avant pour son genou et que
finalement il n'est même pas sorti oui
tu rames célébrer avec des champs le but
de Giro on voit quand même un très bel
esprit dans cette équipe parce que c'est
vrai il y a deux l'occasion de suite et
agiront qui se retrouve seul au 6 mètres
50 là il est un peu du mal avec son pied
gauche puis force un bel arrêt et dans
la foulée le corner 100 de Griezmann le
centre est
exceptionnels
vous avez vu que bon Vincent tiens
justement vous avez vu ça il devait
sortir Olivier Giroud comment ça s'est
passé je suis sûr que vous regardiez des
champs à ce moment-là oui
[Musique]
ben en fait effectivement il y avait
l'air de cette blessé sur une action un
peu avant puis on sentait qu'il allait
qui allait sûrement sortir et voilà la
première action voilà il met une grosse
frappe mais sur pixword on se dit ah là
là il aurait dû la mettre à côté et sur
derrière voilà et sur le sur l'action
juste après sur le centre de Griezmann
ce magnifique centre il va claquer une
tête et moi j'ai envie de parler presque
voilà c'est à l'email jusqu'à fait PEP
euh avec le Portugal en huitième de
finale c'est c'est à dunk en fait il lui
est monté dessus il a il a poussé dans
la cage et puis souvent derrière pu
faire Yoda nous dit mon dieu que c'était
dur on a subi tout le match c'est vrai
qu'on a pas été
une équipe impériale dans cette
rencontre Vincent mais mais c'est quoi
l'important finalement
cette équipe elle est super
on prend l'égalisation beaucoup trop tôt
en deuxième période et derrière on voit
pas le jour on souffre on perd des
ballons les transmissions sont pas
bonnes c'est ça a été vraiment très très
compliqué puis il y a eu cet éclair ce
cette galette de Griezmann pour le coup
de boule de Giroud et derrière bah ça
tient assez solide c'est le mental qui a
encore fait la différence ce soir oui
bien sûr bon on va parler de tous ces
joueurs on va débriefer ce match mais
allez il y a deux moments clés le but de
Giroud on commence par ça Olivier Giroud
il a été une nouvelle fois incroyable
53e but en équipe de France Cindy quel
match parce que il a du mal en première
mi-temps on le voit peu et puis là il y
a trois minutes où il est impressionnant
quoi comme d'habitude et c'est vrai que
c'est un joueur sur lesquels on peut
toujours compter souvent peut-être
contester mais en réalité l'essentiel
est là c'est qu'il fait les jobs et on
peut compter sur lui pour sauver et
surtout que c'est un match si l'on
regarde vraiment les comment ça s'est
déroulée on voit qu'il y a pas mal
défauts qui ont été provoquées parce que
effectivement il y a beaucoup des pertes
des ballons et quand l'Angleterre pousse
un peu la France avec énormément de
pressings et que la France au se
retrouve à subir c'est dans ces
situations là qu'on commence à subir et
avoir beaucoup de fautes et c'est ça qui
a un peu déstabilisé également je pense
l'équipe de France donc pour la suite
parce qu'on va quand même se projeter un
peu de monde je vous prévois tout de
suite je veux pas me projeter là on
vient de se qualifier il y a 7 minutes
tout juste on va se projeter je vous le
premier on a une heure ensemble non là
pour l'instant je veux qu'on parle de ce
qui s'est passé dans ce match Augustin
ce but d'Olivier Giroud alors ce but
d'Olivier Giroud je donne les coulisses
évidemment Thibault demandait
expressément à des chants de ne pas le
sortir à ce moment-là c'est vrai c'est
vrai pourquoi je m'indignais évidemment
voilà et c'est vrai que c'est au moment
où on l'attend pas qui qu'il réagit
toujours et on parlait toujours tout à
l'heure de Mbappé on se demandait s'il a
déjà été aussi fort je me demande si
Jérôme n'a pas été n'a jamais été
en 2018 là il enchaîne il est très
efficace il est moins bon dans le jeu
mais il est efficace et même sur la la
reprise de voler s'il la décale un tout
petit peu elle est dedans
s'attaquant en bleu aujourd'hui n'ont
pas été aussi bon si performante
et ils sont su un peu neutraliser mais
effectivement je pense que nos
attaquants comme il s'était pas trop en
forme c'est vrai que c'est lui qui vient
du ciel un peu du milk c'est presque du
miracle pour le moment que Gilou arrive
à aller prendre et à les mettre parce
que sinon on était en difficulté merci
beaucoup Augustin maurion vous relâche
un instant on accueille
Martin couturier du service des sports
dans un instant je retourne voir Vincent
racontez-moi ce but là la vacances
autour de Olivier Giroud il y a cette
première occasion juste avant Pickford
fait un arrêt et derrière euh maman hors
du temps
et voilà effectivement mort du temps on
a senti vraiment Olivier Giroud hurlé en
plus sur le but enfin voilà on l'a vu
c'était une vraie libération les
Français ils avaient la tête sous l'eau
complètement pendant cette deuxième
période ils se prennent un penalty
derrière il subit ses subissent on s'en
sort bien parce qu'il y aurait plus en
avoir on rappelle après mi-temps un
autre penalty on n'est pas passé très
loin non plus c'était pour n'était pas
très très serein et là voilà Giroud sur
une action voilà qui qui s'élève et qui
marque et on a senti tout le monde se
libérer ils sont allés fêter ça sur le
poteau de corner à l'autre bout du
terrain il y a les remplaçants qui sont
allés courir avec eux c'était vraiment
un super moment de super moment en tout
cas de voilà donc de communion entre les
joueurs on a senti que ça allait là
vraiment libéré regardez cette
statistique mon cher Vincent je vous la
donne la France la première équipe a
remporté un match de Coupe du monde
malgré deux penalty concédés depuis 1966
vous imaginez les Bleus sont assume
merci alors que Martin couturier sur ce
plateau allez-y vous passez devant ma
Martin mais vous avez bien raison Martin
tiens votre première réaction alors
je sais pas ce que vous avez dit
qu'est-ce que ça a été chaud quand même
ah j'aime quand je veux voir énormément
quel match quel match quel deuxième
mi-temps la première mi-temps on l'avait
dit avait été tendu difficile compliqué
la deuxième a été tendue difficile
vous avez raison avait dit dans une
petite interview que j'ai vu à la télé
avant le match ce genre de match va se
jouer sur un détail
de l'histoire effectivement sur
l'expression désormais connu que ce
penalty d’harican raté effectivement
change totalement la donne et change le
résultat de ce match c'est clair ah oui
alors mon avis pour l'instant on avait
envie de célébrer les réussites
françaises et on était sur le but
d'Olivier Giroud racontez-nous vous
comment vous avez vécu le but là oh le
but comment comme comme tout le monde
le live de teddyvette Evano tout de
suite pour que nos internautes puissent
à la seconde ceux qui ont pas la chance
d'être devant leur télé ou au stade
profiter de de l'émotion
Giroud
sortir à ce moment-là j'entendais il est
moins bon dans le jeu mais non
il est bon dans son dans son secteur
dans sa surface dans son petit pré carré
incroyable Giroud 53e but en bleu
recordman
il me fascine honnêtement bien sûr bon
ok mais toujours toujours
incroyable mais c'est que c'est faux oui
il y avait un match dans le match à
distance en vrai et alors Vincent de
Giroud et Kane qui les deux étaient à 52
buts avant la rencontre 125
Giroud finalement égalise et on se dit
Kane à l'opportunité et ben non
dramatique finalement Harry Kane est
peut-être un plus grand joueur c'est
vrai mais l'homme du match ce soir c'est
Olivier ou pas en tout cas haricot parce
qu'il a marqué donc avec sa sélection 53
buts et donc illé
en fait c'est c'est incroyable aussi au
niveau de des attaque et puis comment
oublier les attaquants anglais ils sont
vraiment mis aussi à l'instar des sacs
qui étaient vraiment jouable ils sont
vraiment mis en difficulté nos Français
il faut pas l'oublier oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai ça a eu du boulot allez je
lis ce que nous dit Elena allez les
bleus bravo Thomas du coup bravo les
Bleus Jérémy c'était chaud mais bravo
les Bleus voilà tout le monde est
content évidemment on veut se réjouir
parce que j'ai quelqu'un à côté de moi
là c'est Nicole ménardes il est un peu
ronchonne elle veut se projeter on a mal
joué
vous vous êtes trop dans l'imagination
elle est en demi-finale de la Coupe du
Monde madame c'est un bonheur que on
sort on est mis final de la coupe du
monde
et en fait voilà je pense que parce que
on veut vraiment les voir remporter la
Coupe du Monde c'est pour ça que s'il
faut les céréaliste et voir que dans ces
matchs ont été en difficulté mais il
faut pas non plus oublier que c'est
l'Angleterre c'est une équipe qui est
quand même solide et difficile donc je
pense que les Bleus continuent toujours
à me donner cette impression que tout
est possible
je passe un savon à Vincent roseron vous
nous trouvez des supporters ou vous
faites quoi Vincent là je vois dans le
vent et nous on veut des gens heureux et
ben écoutez je sais tout c'est toujours
pareil c'est toujours pareil vous allez
moi je suis tout seul donc j'essaie de
mettre un endroit où les supporters
sortent et figurez-vous que je me suis
pas mis au volant pour que je supporter
français parce que là c'est pas vraiment
l'endroit où il y a le plus je vois
beaucoup d'Anglais assez triste j'ai
aussi vu alors de des je crois que c'est
des argentins qui sont passés et qui
m'ont dit qu'en gros le football ne
rentre pas à la maison comme le dit la
fameuse phrase de l'anglais de
l'Angleterre mais c'est eux qui rentrent
à la maison
et vous savez quoi alors je vous laisse
deux minutes vous voulez vous prenez
votre petite caméra sous le bras hop et
vous nous trouvez des supporters
français on parle de penalty manqué
d'harica une forcément c'est les deux
moments de ce match ça c'est c'était
très rapide on s'est dit bonheur de
courte du alors d'abord il y a la il y a
la bêtise pardon quelle faute bête de
Hernandez
je vous arrête ah oui là du vrai
supporter allez-y Vincent
regardez regardez on est sur du maillot
98 quand même c'est c'est les toiles et
2018 voilà donc une étoile 0 étoile mais
on en a deux maintenant qu'est-ce que
vous avez demandé de ce match incroyable
une équipe hyper forte on a souffert
mais on s'est tapé on a tout donné et on
peut aller au bon bah aller chercher la
troisième là vous avez beaucoup chanté
énormément chanté on a tout grogné les
Anglais sur les penalties ça a marché et
franchement Giroud Griezmann tout le
monde incroyable Jérôme du mal selon
vous Jérôme du match Giroud homme de
cette coupe du monde pour l'équipe de
France il avait pas marqué en 2018 là il
nous met des buts sur but recordman de
l'équipe de France au niveau des buts
c'est incroyable on y va on va au bout
les gars bon match de Loris quand il
faut pas l'oublier l'or ici il avait un
nombre d'arrêt ce soir incroyable on va
au bout et on a un gros un très très
grand Hugo ce soir merci voilà donc
c'était le c'est un peu le beau c'est
enfin la phrase maintenant c'est on va
au bout et on a retrouvé en plus cette
équipe de 2018 c'est pas flamboyant mais
ça gagne c'est pas flamboyance mais mais
ça joue comme nettement mieux qu'en 2018
une équipe qui a pas beaucoup de plan B
on a énormément de blessés on joue avec
une équipe hyper soudée le groupe est
tous derrière l'entraîneur ça se passe
hyper bien ça on peut vraiment y aller
cette année mais c'est personne n'a
jamais fait à parler brésiliens et les
Uruguayens je pense que là c'est bon on
peut vraiment aller au bout trois
étoiles deuxième étoile d'affilée non
pas à la maison allez on la ramène à la
maison la coupe à la
haine voilà Thibault voilà vous voulez
des supporters français salut Thibault
merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur non mais alors
vous voyez on passe un savon à Vincent
roserand on dirait Mbappé contre la
Pologne on lui dit écoute réveille-toi
mon petit poulet et hop derrière alors
il y a un autre supporter je vois est-ce
qu'il est français il a l'air de se
faire ah non allez-y Vincent vous avez
la main non bon en tout cas il a trouvé
des supporters énervés et qui avait
raison des supporters très chaud c'est
intéressant il nous dit Hey Giroud c'est
l'homme de cette coupe du monde pour les
Bleus dernière c'était Mbappé on verra
au prochain match évidemment allez on
revient sur ce penalty Dary Kane ouais
l'erreur Vincent de Hernandez pourquoi
il fait ça ce coup d'épaule qu'est-ce
que c'est bête franchement elle est
flagrante elle est stupide parce que en
plus mais seulement peut pas l'avoir le
ballon donc c'est c'est vraiment bizarre
ça comme disait Cindy c'est un cadeau
offert aux Anglais et heureusement pour
nous que Harry Kane a eu le pied qui
tremble sur ce coup-là parce que sinon
ça aurait été compliqué
il fait une bêtise irlandaise mais ce
qui reste c'est que Saka était en train
de prendre feu et c'est lui qui l'a un
peu calmé vous avez vu il a un moment il
lui fait un plaquage on dirait il est
battu non en fait je suis là mon petit
gars et derrière il le bien pendant une
dizaine de minutes et ça casse c'est à
nouveau éteint oui parce qu'il était
valable dans ces matchs
et puis on a pas beaucoup parlé des
Griezmann
était sur le penalty qui est intéressant
exactement il y a deux choses à dire
allez-y moi il y a deux choses à dire
sur un pédo comme ça le premier c'est
que et tout le monde s'en fout de ce que
je vais vous dire mais c'est pas grave
j'ai noté que vous avez souvent fauteuil
d'honneur
vous êtes tout seul regardez vous êtes
en majesté vous êtes superbes donc
allez-y vous allez donc noté que les
joueurs qui tirent à penalty sans
prendre beaucoup d'élan en plus tendance
à rater que ceux qui prennent beaucoup
d'élan oui mais alors le premier penalty
c'est le parkaïne je ne dis pas que à
chaque fois voilà je dis que c'est j'ai
remarqué ça j'aimerais bien la course au
milieu de terrain hop quasiment donc je
n'aime pas cette erreurs qui font un
quart de mie voilà c'est c'est mon
premier deuxième chose je suis sûr
qu'effectivement le fait que Hugo Lloris
soit dans les buts pour le deuxième a
quand même joué déjà lors du premier il
avait retouché le ballon notre ami Kane
il était déjà pas serein et ça on était
sorti et là je pense que ce refaire le
coup face à son pote de club ça a été
compliqué pour lui émotionnellement et
ça ça a payé regardez la preuve que
cette génération est dorée l'équipe de
France est le premier tenant du titre de
la Coupe du monde à atteindre les
demi-finales depuis le Brésil en 98 vous
imaginez on espère que ça se passe
franchement je pense que on a du mal à
se rendre compte les jeunes vous vous
rendez pas bien ce que vous avez c'est
vrai moi j'ai connu une équipe je suis
né sous une équipe de France qui n'a
fait que gagner ou presque alors que
Vincent Duchesne qui est beaucoup plus
vieux que moi a connu une équipe de
France qui ne se qualifiait pas pour la
Coupe du Monde on a connu 94
Vincent roseron cette statistique elle
est impressionnante vous aussi vous êtes
d'une génération gâtée avec les Bleus
vous avez vu première fois que les une
équipe retourne en demi-finale après
avoir gagné la Coupe du Monde depuis le
Brésil en 98
alors je suis assez jeune aussi donc
effectivement alors on pourra dire quand
même qu'on avait connu un petit trou
d'air 2008 2010 2012 mais 2014 on a
senti que ça partait mieux et oui
forcément là on le sent il y a une vraie
équipe les statistiques elles sont
incroyables de cet équivalent on a gagné
une Coupe du Monde on retourne en
demi-finale je veux pas me projeter mais
on va être favori on va voir ce qui va
ce qui va se passer mais en tout cas le
doubler il est possible très bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr vous relâchez pas
Vincent vous avez eu deux très bons
supporters ça me suffit pas moi je veux
des gens un peu énervé autour de vous
donc vous me les retrouvez et on en veut
encore aller
je vous en ai pas parlé de rater de
Harry Kane vous aussi vous êtes dit hein
peut-être que là le deuxième le choix
est plus difficile ou pas c'est non je
pense que c'est tout simplement que le
lit ça fait aussi un très bon match il
faut le souligner et ça ça porte aussi
beaucoup d'assurance à l'équipe de
France je pense que pour aller plus loin
c'est vraiment ce qu'il fallait c'est
vraiment c'est d'abord la seule chose
qui me gêne c'est si on parle un peu de
cette somme là bon bah la défense pas
énormément des rassure pas au fait pour
la suite donc c'est des éléments qu'il
faut pour la suite bon Charles Martel
lui-même voilà quand on parle des
Anglais par contre Mbappé oui c'est un
fidèle par contre elle m'appelle a été
assez transparent voilà ce qui nous dit
sur Le Figaro.fr on va y venir justement
je disais en avant match en a longtemps
parlé Martin sans Mbappé si Mbappé est
éteint qu'est-ce qu'on fait
Mbappe pas là non Cindy il y a des
choses à dire dites-moi alors vous avez
la parole bapé il y a aussi été sur
sollicité sur sa sonne on voit qu'il
s'attaquait plutôt à gauche mais il y a
une réalité il fait ses faces avec des
duels à Walker qui a été très très bon
dans les duels donc je pense que ça joue
aussi un petit peu c'est vrai que
c'était pas les meilleurs matchs de
Killian Mbappé mais il a quand même fait
les jobs parce que il contribue au fait
à ces résultats là
sur le dos ça passe pas ça passe pas il
fait pas mauvais match en fait mais il
peut pas faire plus que ce qu'il fait là
parce qu'il y a trop de monde sur lui
qui a pas de place il y a pas
d'ouverture il y a pas d'espace il y a
pas tout ce qu'il aime d'habitude pour
faire la différence donc il fait
pression il mobilise du monde ça ça
forcément libère un peu de place à côté
et au final il fait son match voilà il y
a pas d'exploit il y a pas des coups
d'éclats mais c'est pas grave il y a
besoin d'espace pour s'exprimer
à partir de ce moment-là c'est compliqué
pour lui on peut pas lui demander des
miracles non plus c'est pas c'est pas
l'objectif non plus finalement c'est de
c'est une victoire en équipe celle-là
finalement on parlait de ça avant le bac
c'est une victoire du collectif c'est
presque plus beau finalement je lis ce
que nous disent nos internautes sur
Youtube notamment bravo l'équipe de
France rendez-vous en finale contre
l'Argentine bon on va gagner le Maroc
difficilement mais faut pas perdre
contre l'Argentine derrière voilà ce que
me dit Samia sont mal peut-être un peu
on va parler de la suite mais attention
le Maroc qui est là et l'Argentine n'a
pas encore gagné non plus sa demi-finale
oui c'est vrai que c'est assez étonnant
cette équipe de France parce que vous en
pensez l'impression qu'elle joue au
moment où elle est en danger
c'est-à-dire bon allez on se met à
l'abri tout de suite à zéro zéro Mark
après on se laisse faire ah on a pris un
but hop on se remet à jouer c'est bon on
est devant on se laisse à nouveau faire
force pas quoi non mais c'est pas
l'impression que ça vous donne on joue
quand on en a besoin et sinon le reste
du temps on attend ça c'est presque le
côté un peu positif que vous voyez de
cette affaire là moi je sais pas si
c'est positif mais on a l'impression
qu'ils sont un peu à réaction quoi bon
moi je prends ce que j'ai l'impression
quand même qu'il y a un manque de
maîtrise quand même sur cette base on en
parlait nous déjà en première mi-temps
vous vous étiez un petit peu plus
positif que nous nous avec Cindy et
Vincent de mémoire on était quand même
assez pas négatif mais en tout cas
interrogatif sur cette première mi-temps
compliquée la seconde là était tout
autant il y a finalement les Anglais ont
continué à beaucoup pousser peut-être
pas se créer énormément d'occasions mais
encore à s'en créer
et par un coup justement ce que je veux
vous dire c'est qu'à ce moment efficace
à ce moment-là est-ce que le football
technique Beaujeu ça n'existe plus on
est en quart de finale de la Coupe du
Monde
du manque des pressings en fait parce
que moi je dis là vous me parlez
tactique technique il faut presser non
ça n'existe pas à ce moment-là il y a
plus que ça qui compte il y a plus que
ça le reste ça n'existe plus il y a 11
joueurs sur le terrain qui sont ils
écoutent plus les consignes de défend
ils en ont plus rien à faire c'est 11
joueurs qui veulent gagner Giroud sur ce
centre il pense pas d'échange me place
comme-ci comme ça j'ai pas pressé il
veut mettre la tête au fond des filets
pour mettre le but voyez ce que je veux
dire ça n'existe plus la tactique à ce
moment-là non mais moi je parle pas des
tactique je parle des langues vie en
fait moi j'aime bien voir des équipes
qui ont beaucoup envie de ballon qui est
le Ken le ballon là le ballon
oui et c'est pressing moi je l'ai vu du
côté anglais d'ailleurs si vraiment vous
voulez que je sois très très réaliste
sur et objectif sur l'analyse des images
même si je suis pour les Bleus les
sangliers ont les plus mérité de gagner
ces matchs ne se laissent que parce
qu'ils sont mis des langues et c'est là
superbe et l'équipe de France et qui
arrive quand même à gagner alors que les
autres ils sont peut-être été un petit
peu dessus Vincent vous êtes pas
d'accord avec moi vous je suis plutôt
d'accord avec Cindy je suis désolé
j'ai des gens qui me disent on est en
demi-finale de la Coupe du monde et vous
me dites on aurait dû mieux faire en
demi-finale de la Coupe du Monde
on peut pas mieux faire que ça on a
gagné le match si vous voulez 15 tirs
contre un pour la France la France a
gagné le match les anglais sont à la
maison qui a réussi ça
a été compliqué on a été en soufflant
mais c'est là notre grandeur ce qu'on a
rivol l'équipe de France a gagné dans
des situations les plus difficiles et
c'est pour ça qu'on a été le champion du
monde en 2018 vous savez ce qu'on va
faire on va donner la parole à Vincent
roseron ou plutôt aux gens qui
l'accompagnent ou ils sont flous les
gens qui accompagnent Vincent
ça y est on les récupère Vincent vous
avez la parole
qui est venu avec sa femme Catherine
pour pouvoir ce match alors on avance
c'est quoi ce match de l'équipe de
France superbe extrêmement stressant
mais très bien joué
un petit peu
ouais super alors technique
techniquement des superbes coups c'était
vraiment agréable on a quand même
souffert pendant ce match on a été super
stressé tout le temps voilà merci à
notre gardien bravo Hugo qui a tout
arrêté c'est le meilleur joueur du match
pardon c'est lui le meilleur joueur pour
vous du match probablement oui ah oui il
a été là où il fallait et une petite
question sur ce penalty le deuxième
d'Harry Kane qu'est-ce que ça vous a
fait comme action
mérité parce que gagner sur des
penalties si on te après le penalty
était mérité mais un plaisir non non
mais deux on fait n'importe quoi dans la
surface aussi non c'était mérité le
penalty mais gagner sur la base de
penalty c'est dommage alors que nous on
avait des super buts c'est vrai
effectivement bon et du coup cette
équipe de France elle va jusqu'où
maintenant
on va on va prendre le temps une superbe
demi-finale problème
ont une superbe énergie ça va être un
pas facile mais bon moi j'attends la
finale voilà et ben voilà on attend la
finale et bien sûr on attend la
troisième étoile pourquoi pas qui c'est
alors je rêve parce que tout le monde
nous dit alors déjà ils ont raison ça
c'est vrai minable de gagner sur des
penalties donc il y a une justice voilà
ce que nous dit supporters tout le monde
ne voit pas c'est le Maroc je lis
d'ailleurs Adrien on est en finale le
Maroc dans la poche on va en parler du
Maroc mais on a encore un peu de temps
on a encore un peu de temps parce que
nous sommes là jusqu'à au moins 23
heures et pour l'instant nous parlons de
de ce match on a parlé de Mbappé on a
parlé de Jo où on a parlé d'Harry Kane
finalement homme du mal il a été très
bon avec Kane avant de rater ce penalty
c'est vrai parlons de Griezmann vous
vouliez me parler de Griezmann c'est une
Nicole ménardes
on en parle pas souvent et moi je trouve
qu'on devrait les faire plus depuis
qu'il se trouve dans ces placements au
milieu il dit je vais c'est c'est lui un
peu les cerveaux moi j'ai dit les de
l'équipe de France je l'ai trouvé bon
dans ces matchs d'ailleurs
on a une relation comme Giroud Mbappe
vous et moi on s'entend pas hyper bien
et puis après ça va ça y est
Antoine Griezmann
vous voyez ce que je veux dire bon
allez-y va parlez-moi d'Antoine
Griezmann
j'ai du mal à me rendre compte en fait
j'ai l'impression que c'est devenu un
milieu de terrain défensif
quoi c'est un numéro 8 à l'ancienne quoi
où il vient apporter son écho
défensivement il essaie d'apporter du
lion mais là ça a été compliqué
techniquement aujourd'hui quand même il
y a eu pas mal de mauvaises passes
pendant un quart d'heure
la deuxième période ça a été une
catastrophe sur le plan technique on a
perdu beaucoup de ballons facile et mais
on est final ce qui est vrai mais on est
mal mais il faut quand même voilà
c'était quand même pas glorieux glorieux
aussi
mais le résultat est là le résultat est
là est encore raté pour les anglais
parce qu'on peut dire un petit mot sur
les Anglais quand même finalement un
petit mot des Anglais mais d'abord je
vais demander à Vincent roseron ce qu'il
en pense parce que là c'est presque une
question philosophique qu'on se pose là
non mais très franchement
est-ce que
on demande à Vincent
est-ce que dans un quart de finale on
parle encore ballon ou finalement bah
non là il y a que de la joie il y a une
qualification il y a que ça qui compte
pardon
je m'appelle Eddy alors la caméra est
ici alors vous avez pensé quoi de ce
match franchement c'est un match très
très difficile très physique on a
beaucoup subi mais franchement c'est
bien battu on a répondu au duels
physiques que nous ont proposé les
Anglais courageuse cette équipe de
France vraiment très courageuse avec un
Giroud devant héroïque
rabiot au milieu qui s'est très bien
battu de choix ménik et il nous sort un
éclair de sortie de nulle part et après
on a tenu Lloris a sorti des beaux
arrêts aussi mais on s'y attendait à un
match très difficile contre une très
belle équipe d'Angleterre et là on est
en demi on est en demi et franchement
quand on regarde le tableau on se dit
que c'est assez ouvert on est confiant
mais faut pas trop s'enflammer non plus
bien sûr mais on y croit bien c'est le
troisième étoiles on veut garder la
coupe on veut la ramener à la maison
maintenant on veut la garder à la maison
donc on peut le faire on peut le faire
et c'est un très beau match contre le
Maroc en demi-finale donc
faudra le gagner et aller jusqu'au bout
et on peut le faire super merci beaucoup
en tout cas bonne soirée merci
voilà Thibault et du coup je n'ai pas du
tout entendu la question philosophique
que vous voulez me poser je vous la
repose ce qu'à ce moment-là en quart de
finale et vous nous dites vous
d'ailleurs sur le chat de YouTube sur
celui du figaro.fr est-ce qu'à ce
moment-là qualifier en demi-finale on
peut encore parler de tactique technique
c'est ce que pense mes amis sur ce
plateau moi je pense que et bien on
gagne et que c'est la seule chose qui
compte finalement vous en pensez quoi
vous
oui il n'y a que la victoire qui va
alors avant toute avant tout ça parce
que Martin m'a dit pourquoi est-ce qu'on
va le voir lui pour pas parler philo
effectivement j'ai huit au bac philo
donc à priori c'est pas vers moi qu'il
faudrait aller mais bon sinon ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'effectivement il
faut toujours parler technique toujours
parler tactiques toujours analyser ce
match parce que oui ça va jouer sur ça
aussi un match il y a pas voilà c'est
forcément là on est dans l'émotion on a
une demi-heure après le match donc
forcément c'est les c'est l'émotion qui
prime et ça joue aussi beaucoup mental
mais oui ça joue aussi beaucoup sur la
technique il faut réussir ses contrôles
il faut réussir à bien embêter il va
falloir bien embêter cette équipe
marocaine qui a montré que si on a pas
des bonnes idées pour la mettre en
danger bah on la mettra pas en danger en
fait surtout des Bleus fabuleux de
courage ah oui vous voulez répondre à
Vincent vous avez huit en philo au bac
c'est deux fois plus que moi oui
magnifique alors l'escalade du pire
Vincent vous avez combien
j'ai eu quatre en philosophes comme vous
voyez ça mène à tout vous pouvez même
devenir un acteur en chef du service de
sport du Figaro je vous dis ce que dit
Baptiste Després qui était dans le stade
des Bleus fabuleux de courage
une grande équipe anglaise ne surtout
pas galvauder cette qualification on a
vu une équipe solide courageuse faite
d'abnégation à l'image de Griezmann
Rabiau ou encore ou pas mécano et Loris
les ingrédients 2018 sont toujours là
bien vivants
Christophe remise au bout de l'effort
avec le soupçon de réussite qui va bien
et ce penalty manquer de Ken à la fin
les Bleus sont en demi-finale et ce
malgré un Mbappé bien pris voilà
l'histoire du courage victoire d'une
équipe et Baptiste une qualification pas
de blessé pas de suspendu la soirée est
idéale
donc ça veut dire que théoriquement tout
se passe bien
cette équipe 11 de départ repartira
contre le Maroc là exactement dans un
match qui sera très différent je sais
pas quel moment vous voulez on va y
venir évidemment on va attendre un petit
peu tiens oui si on devait faire un
changement peut-être ou pas mécano
est-ce qu'il a rassuré dans ce match
cette nuit
il commence à être en confiance il a
fait quand même des bons matchs par les
autres matchs de la Coupe du monde donc
est-ce qu'on va s'arrêter sur ça et ce
qu'on a assez aussi d'effectif sur les
bancs pour pouvoir les changer et puis
complètement perdre les perdre parce que
finalement si on les sort du 11 on bat
les perdre ou pas mécano qui est un
joueur jaune moi je pense qu'il faut
quand même continuer à lui donner sa
chance surtout la question des
automatismes avec Raphaël varan mais il
commence tous les deux à jouer ensemble
depuis quelques matchs si on commence à
sortir ou pas mécano pour mettre un
autre joueur à côté de Varane c'est
compliqué je remercie Martin couturier
de nous avoir accompagnés des Sports à
disposition complètement et on se met à
disposition du service des sports aussi
totalement tout ce que vous faites
depuis le début Thibault mais on fait ce
qu'on peut
on aura les notes dans un instant de
Baptiste et Christophe qui sont dans le
stade qui travaille très vite et on les
aura sur le sur le site on a déjà
ensemble c'est notre j'aime bien ça
Vincent je vous donne la parole
faites-nous un petit bilan votre
ressenti d'ailleurs les supporters
étaient plutôt français ou anglais dans
dans ce stade et dans un instant on
parle des réseaux sociaux ce qui s'est
passé sur Internet
alors côté supporters c'était plutôt du
côté des Anglais que ça a plutôt poussé
clairement on était allé sur du 2/3 1/3
côté anglais j'ai l'impression mais on
entendait quand même bien les Français
chanter mais ouais on a beaucoup on a
plus entendu les Anglais pas beaucoup
plus mais plus vous parlez de pas mécano
tout à l'heure ou pas mécano moi j'ai
quand même une petite remarque à vous
faire c'est que dans des matchs comme ça
pour marquer des buts il faut des
dépassements de fonction et le premier
but il vient de qui et ben il vient d'où
pas mes cadeaux alors certes il se fait
complètement enrhumer par Kane juste
derrière il y a quelques moments où on
lui demande de bien défendre
effectivement il y est pas mais par
contre le pré but il vient de lui quand
même et il fait pas il fait pas un
mauvais match alors je voudrais pas je
sais pas combien on lui a mis en note
mais par exemple je l'ai trouvé alors on
l'a plus vu ce qui est pas forcément une
bonne chose pour un défenseur mais que
Raphaël Varane par exemple
alors on va faire les notes dans un
instant Vincent vous restez avec nous
Vincent ça s'est vidé assez vite là les
supporters français sont partis
rapidement
expliquez-moi vous êtes loin de doigt là
comment ça se passe pour les Bleus
alors là on est au stade qui est le plus
loin de doigts pour la Coupe du Monde au
stade d'albike qui est ici voilà que je
vous montre ici en fait ce stade il est
alors je sais pas une quarantaine de
kilomètres au nord de doigts et il est
grosso modo à une heure de route pour y
aller une heure de route ou alors il
faut prendre un bus puis en métro c'est
pas comme le stade d'hier par exemple
pour l'Argentine ou en fait tout est
relié en métro très rapidement là pour
le coup vraiment c'est un peu plus
compliqué on va dire pour venir au stade
et du coup on voit des gens partir dès
la fin du match pour aller chercher leur
voiture ou pour attraper des bus parce
que là tout le monde va rentrer en bus
sinon il va y avoir quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de monde sur la route vous avez
un supporter ravi derrière vous mon cher
Vincent on revient vers vous dans un
instant on parle des Bleus on fera les
notes des Bleus dans dans quelques
secondes on parlera évidemment du Maroc
parce que c'est le prochain adversaire
de l'équipe de France c'est mercredi
mais avant on regarde ce qu'il s'est
passé sur les réseaux sociaux Tang
travailler vous êtes avec nous alors
racontez-moi qu'est-ce que vous avez vu
pendant cette rencontre cette victoire
des Bleus de Buzard je vais vous montrer
des tweets assez drôles dans un instant
mais déjà je trouve j'ai trouvé les
tutos immensément joyeux ce soir j'ai
bien scruté le réseau social et à chaque
fois vous savez je vous donne un chiffre
qui illustre la frénésie un petit peu
qui se déroule sur le réseau et je crois
qu'il y a eu 565 tweets publiés par
seconde au moment de la tête d'Olivier
alors ça ça c'est toujours très étonnant
c'est à dire que vraiment les gens
réagissent au moment des buts quoi vous
en êtes friand de cette courbe et donc
oui effectivement on voit le nombre de
postes aux différents moments de la de
la partie on voit le but d'Aurélien
chaumini qui a suscité nombre de
réactions évidemment la tête libératrice
c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est-à-dire que le but de choix mini a
plus de poste que lors de du penalty de
légalisation de l'Angleterre explosion
au moment du but d'Olivier Giroud et
alors après à nouveau le penalty des
Anglais là il suscite moins de réaction
quand même moins de réaction plus de
réactions par rapport au but de regarder
plus on avance plus les gens sont chauds
quoi tout à fait 565 tweets par seconde
au moment de la tête de Olivier c'est
non c'est qui visible notre remercie
notre partenaire routier de veille des
réseaux sociaux et je parlais de Giroud
il y a une seconde on va voir un tweet
qui illustre bien sa pensée normalement
il va arriver on va voir en régie est-ce
qu'on a le tweet autour d'Olivier Giroud
c'est ça tout à fait ah non alors
d'abord on a ça c'est ah oui j'aime
beaucoup ça effectivement le diagramme
j'ai anticipé alors attendez avant de
voir le but de géo ah le joueur qui fait
le plus parler de lui c'est ça tout à
fait et assez étonnamment c'est encore
Kylian Mbappé qui qui enflamme la toile
pourtant il a pas été si en vue que ça
sur cette rencontre après évidemment
c'est kif qu'il faut Livier Giroud et
auréliene finalement les deux buteurs et
puis tu as mini aussi on sait aussi
qu'il a été impliqué sur le le premier
penalty et puis suivre effectivement
Hugo Lloris encore grandiose ce soir et
Antoine Griezman qui est souvent dans le
coup parce que
les réseaux l'adorent ou adorent aussi
le critiquer c'est un petit peu voilà
j'imagine qu'elle m'a payé il a été
critiqué bon ce tweet alors le tweet il
est il est là je puisse ma force en
Jésus-Christ la foi d'Olivier Giroud
inébranlable souvent et tout à fait tout
à fait donc ça a encore marché ce soir
évidemment ensuite on a un autre tweet
on parlait beaucoup en en dans le dans
le before du duel avec Kyl Walker on a
vu sur on a eu qu'une seule fois le duel
sur une seule accélération c'est vrai
mais il a su le passé et donc ce tweet
qui dit qu'il est tout simplement trop
rapide avec Kai Walker qui tire un petit
peu le maillot de de Kylian Mbappe alors
ça c'est très très drôle j'ai trouvé en
tout cas ballon bien réceptionné merci
avec Kane ah oui
de Thomas Pesquet ah j'aime beaucoup
officiel c'est c'est
pas la petite pastille bleue mais oui
c'est vrai alors il y a toujours les
pastilles bleues maintenant
je ne pensez jamais mais ça c'est pas le
compte officiel de Thomas
j'aurais été encore plus marquant
sur le tweet sur le penalty raté et donc
là on a tous vu cette réaction de de
Kylian Mbappe justement après ce penalty
raté d'Harry Ken ou un peu à l'instar
des hier des Argentins vous savez vous
avez vu ces photos qui sont moqués
ouvertement des des
Pays-Bas et donc là
ça se trouve c'est juste à un moment de
voilà de joie quoi de soulagement
finalement mais on entend le la dans le
sourire et bien fait et bien fait quoi
ah on sent un peu ça chez Mbappé
alors merci la transition est tout
trouvé parce que le prochain tweet que
j'ai sélectionné pour vous c'est
justement les petites gifles après la
lydiele de la rencontre face à la
Pologne où ils se sont fait un petit
regard presque charnel et ben là il y a
eu des une sorte de claque amical
évidemment
les Gilou et bah oui c'est vrai il faut
assumer maintenant je veux pas avoir de
problème vous voyez je bon je l'ai
recevrai je serai heureux voilà bon donc
c'est vrai mais Mbappé immensément
heureux et qu'il a qu'il a démontré ce
soir encore une fois encore deux petits
tweets à vous montrer alors ça je sais
pas ce que vous en avez pensé mais il y
a un Twitter ce qui a remarqué un petit
peu le l'aspect pleurnicheur des Anglais
qui venaient tout le temps se plaindre
et donc les Anglais dès qu'un Français
est près d'eux et qui se sont rouler par
terre selon ce Twitter
évidemment on voit avec les chaussures
jaunes
et puis alors le dernier tweet parce
qu'on se projette évidemment sur la
suite de la compétition d'idées
Deschamps en conquérant Napoléon ah
c'est drôle ça oui
et donc peut-être en route vers la
troisième étoile magnifique tableau de
David normalement et là c'est Didier
Deschamps donc sur ce cheval magnifique
merci beaucoup Tony soyez tiens euh
Vincent vous aussi vous avez trouvé que
les Anglais se roulaient par terre on
faisait un peu trop moi j'ai pas
forcément senti ça dans la télé
non pas forcément j'ai pas trop vu ça on
est sans senti très énervé sur les
penalties en fait parce que par exemple
sur le sur le premier sur le premier
penalty par exemple
Jul belingham tombe à terre juste avant
que je suis que sur qui est la faute sur
sa cage je crois sur le penalty il se
plaint il s'est déjà plein il se plaint
aussi 10 minutes après pareil dans la
surface ils en ont un peu voulu à cet
arbitre mais je pense pas qu'ils
accuseront là l'arbitrage lors de ce
match comme l'a fait à certains Lionel
Messi hier alors qu'il a été quand même
un peu gâté par arbitrage effectivement
donc voilà donc j'ai pas forcément
trouvé que cette que ce que cet
arbitrage était vraiment
problématique en tout cas où ou les
Anglais ont mal réagi c'est le sport
c'est un quart de finale il jouait gros
et donc forcément on va les émotions
sont décuplées et et voilà il fallait
marquer son penalty surtout pour aller
Kane beaucoup plus Tanguy votre petit
tweet de Thomas Pesquier là le troll de
Pesquet est sublime alors c'est pas
Thomas Pesquet tiens Vincent roseron je
reste avec vous on va commencer à faire
les notes du match vous savez on prend
toujours le temps on a les notes qu'on
donnait nos envahies spéciaux Christophe
remise et Baptiste des frais qui sont
dans le stade tiens je vous avais la
parole vous avez l'honneur de noter le
gardien Hugo Lloris selon vous quelle
note expliquez-moi pourquoi
alors Hugo Lloris on va lui mettre on va
lui mettre 7 parce qu'il faudrait
peut-être presque 1 8 mais il a été
solide il peut rien sur le penalty
clairement il se prend une minasse il a
pas souvent été voilà il a pas été
parfait au pied mais ça c'est on a
l'habitude mais par contre il a sorti
des parades absolument
exceptionnel l'arrêt qui fait qu'on peut
mécano se fait se fait sortir il sort
très très vite sur Kane c'est vraiment
incroyable donc cette allez 7 et demi
parce que j'arrive pas trop à trancher
entre 7 et 8 vous avez trouvé la bonne
note vous mettez nous vous aussi une
Minase en pleine lucarne pour l'arrivée
de Teddy vadévalu comment ça va c'est
bien passé ce live très bien très bien
je peux revoir ce que vous avez écrit
donc je peux voir ce que vous avez écrit
sur le but d'arrêter et dire alors vous
savez ce que je vais faire pendant que
vous me donnez la note comme ça on
rentre dans le bain parce qu'on commence
à faire sur la note que vous dormiriez à
Hugo Lloris et bien je cherche vous avez
écrit
parce que il a été on ne peut plus
décisifs je crois que derrière une
défense qui a été un peu un peu ballotée
dans tous les sens il a il a il a
cherché à la rassurer justement au bon
capitaine le jour en plus de du match
qui qui le donne encore men de de match
en équipe de France je trouve que c'est
un beau c'est un bol donc donc oui je
leur ai donné 8 racontais simplement les
Bleus reprennent l'avantage
[Musique]
Griezmann envoie un centre 1000 litres
pour Giraud qui cette fois-ci trompe
ficford d'un coup de tête décider oui ça
coûte peut-être décidé combien elle est
rapidement quelle date vous auriez donné
et vous nous dites-vous sur Le Figaro.fr
et sur Youtube la note que vous donnez à
chacun des joueurs good le risque
combien vous lui donnez rien allez je
vais donner 7 je suis un tout petit peu
plus mesquin parce que en soit c'est pas
lui qui sort vraiment le penalty
d'arrêter parce que c'est avec qui le
tire dans la stratosphère quand même
référence au tweet mais sinon oui là on
pinaille un peu c'est vraiment le
dernier par des bleus je trouve qu'il
manque il monte vraiment en puissance au
fur et à mesure de la compétition sans
la note que vous donnez à le risque moi
je coupe la peau en deux c'était demi
tout le monde est d'accord le très bon
match Harry Kane rate ce penalty tout en
majuscule incredible vous êtes permis
l'attaque
et vous pouvez retrouver c'est plutôt
rigolo hein d'ailleurs on a les même les
photos et tout vous êtes bons oui je
suis beau je sais pas mais
maintenant
allez on continue à noter les Bleus
tiens euh
le latéral droit Jules kunday allez
chacun rapidement c'est un espace sur le
coude dès qu'on vient vous lui donnez un
petit un petit 6
trouver un petit peu en délicatesse mais
pas pas tant que ça finalement donc une
note tu peux au dessus de la moyenne 4
j'aime pas j'aime pas le joueur
j'aime pas Cristiano Ronaldo mais bon
j'ai beaucoup Cristiano Ronaldo
se comporter sur un terrain enfin je
trouve qu'il est fébrile il est le son
bodylanway j'ai tout respire la
fébrilité en lui donc il l'a prouvé
encore aujourd'hui attendez parce que
sinon nous on montre je demande à Riad
Becker de montrer ce que vous écrivez je
suis sûr qu'on peut trouver des fautes
d'orthographe voilà c'est ça
allez on continue combien vous donner
Vincent un match correct il a tenu son
Orange il a pas voilà rien de plus allez
j'ai le coude voilà il lui en donner 5
également on est parfois frustré de son
peu d'appétence pour le jeu offensif
Raphaël Varane ou pas mécano on essaie
de les noter l'un et l'autre ensemble
qui était le meilleur des deux tiens
Vincent pour vous Varane ou pas mécano
était le meilleur genre vous m'avez dit
pas mécano finalement il est pas mal
même si on l'a vu en début de match en
difficulté quand même face vous avez
expliqué que si il a été il fait alors
je sais pas si c'est à 16h sur la que
vous parlez du coup mais ou pas les
cadeaux oui parce que moi je viens de
lui donc
excusez-moi je connais pas la
compétition
le Oui ou pas mécano il amène un peu le
but forcément il est un peu fébrile
après il met ouais je mettrai un 6 à lui
et un sac à barade et juste alors je
suis désolé je voulais juste revenir un
tout petit peu en arrière sur Lloris
parce que je voulais juste qu'on se
rappelle quand même que les Anglais nous
avaient dit delania pic Ford on a le
meilleur gardien par rapport à Hugo
Lloris vous avez raison Hugo Lloris a
bien répondu ouais magnifique vous avez
raison il donne des notes assez faibles
aux deux défenseurs sans trop Tangui
vous leur donnez combien
je vous donnerai 6 parce que je trouve
qu'il a tenu la baraque derrière il a
été assez rassurant alors pour le coup
là je dis aussi vraiment avec ou pas
mécano parce qu'on peut americano nous a
fait quelques frayeurs en première
période donc c'est pour ça que je lui
mettrai la note de 3 3 ah oui vous êtes
dur
non vous n'êtes pas d'accord la réponse
en face non si c'est pour Varane et si
c'est lui je pense pour ou pas du tout
d'accord oui mais moi je suis d'accord
avec avec Tanguy c'est à dire que il a
fait un bon match après mais ces deux
erreurs elle coûte tellement cher c'est
ça
but de Kane
du penalty vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est à dire que un défenseur et un
attaquant on attend qu'est-ce que vous
nous dites Vincent
oui mais sans lui il y a pas le premier
but aussi donc il faut quand même le
prendre en compte c'est à dire ou pas
mécano
bah mes cadeaux c'est lui qui amène le
premier but c'est ou pas mécanique qui
sort ce ballon qui fait qui fait le rush
sur le premier oui
un quart d'heure pas de problème Vincent
il aura touché le ballon ou pas
écoute écoutez écoutez moi moi j'ai
l'impression que te dit valait Valou qui
s'y connaît très bien en sport et à peu
près d'accord avec moi ce qui me suffit
bon parfait
votre avis moi je mettrai un 5 à Raphaël
Varane et un quatre et demi pour ou pas
mécano parce que on voit trop ses
erreurs c'est trop importantes et mine
de rien heureusement qu'il y avait Hugo
Lloris derrière parce que sinon ça se
paye cash et bien vous voyez le cigare
est partagé parce que Raphaël Varane a
reçu la note de 6,5 le manque une nuit
le Mancunien a diffusé un sentiment de
sérénité tout au long de la rencontre
taulier ou pas mécano ils lui ont donné
avec plusieurs interventions musclées
voilà bon le seul oubli de pas mécano au
départ c'est l'action du but de chaumini
bon voilà chacun son avis sur cette
question mais ils sont d'accord avec
vous oui c'était bien racheté en fait
par la suite avec des bons TACs voilà il
a amené du caractère
combien vous lui donnez 4 et demi c'est
dur parce que tu es tellement bête en
fait le ballon est complètement enfin il
est hors de portée de Messenger sur
lequel il fait faute et rien que pour ça
je trouve que c'est une faute terrible
et bon si Ken avait égalisé bon on n'est
pas dans Football fiction mais si vous
êtes contradictoire vous me dites coupa
mecano et si Kane avait marqué mais ou
pas mécanes aussi
[Rires]
l'autre ça va pas non mais je trouve
qu'une balade ça ramène un penalty quoi
donc je trouve que la faute est encore
plus grotesque d'accord moi j'ai trouvé
très bon pour enterrer sa CAQ quand il
s'est mis à être à être en feu vous
voyez ce que je veux dire d'un seul coup
mais il a ce placage derrière il a ce
retour vous savez où il se fait pousser
dans le dos lui sur un centre qui arrive
sur Saka je le trouve à ce moment là que
pendant 10 minutes est en train de
prendre feu d'un seul coup il reprend
l'avantage combien vous lui donnez-nous
Vincent moi je lui mettrais 4 à cause de
ça de cette belle vue là cette grossière
erreur et puis il a vraiment souffert
face à Saka en deuxième période donc 4
c'est mérité bon vous Tanguy ouais match
en plusieurs temps évidemment les
fautifs sur le penalty je lui donnerai 5
parce que je l'ai trouvé très
intéressant offensivement bon alors la
note est bien c'est un 5 pour Théo
Hernandez Aurélien de choix béni buteur
combien vous lui donnez vous Vincent
Duchêne c'est compliqué ouais il est
compliqué à noter parce qu'on a vraiment
pris le bouillon en deuxième période au
milieu de terrain il marque un but
fantastique sans élan où je suis
mettrait 5 et demi et voilà c'est la
note qui lui a donné c'est vrai c'est un
ennemi parce qu'il fait pas un très bon
match comme ça
dans un match comme celui-là le plus dur
c'est d'ouvrir le score et je trouve
qu'il a eu le mérite justement de
tranquilliser en plus l'équipe de France
dans sa stratégie de de rester derrière
et de contrer grâce à ce but on a la
déclaration d'Olivier Giroud et on va
continuer ses notes évidemment tous
ensemble c'est extraordinaire ça me
rappelle un peu la Belgique en 2018
c'était un très gros match je suis super
fier de cette équipe j'espère qu'on ira
le plus loin possible c'est vrai que les
Bleus ont pas été dominants comme contre
la Belgique il y a 4 ans mais finalement
c'est eux qui s'impose allez on remonte
le fil de cette composition d'équipe
Aurélien de famille a eu 5,5 sur Le
Figaro.fr vous n'hésitez pas vous aussi
à noter sur Youtube et sur notre notre
chat sur la home page du Figaro Adrien
rabiot elle était très ma vie
d'accord non allez-y évidemment non
j'allais dire qu'il avait été bon là où
on l'attendait pas et un peu moins bon
là où on l'attendait donc comme il a un
petit peu dépassé ses fonctions je vous
donnerai la note de 5 et demi et voilà
vous aussi c'est facile maintenant je
vous ai donné le résultat de coller
spéciaux Adrien Raviot tiens je vais lui
donner combien garder la parole je garde
la main Adrien rabiot non non
incontestablement peut-être
le meilleur français de la partie parce
qu'il a il a pesé de tout son poids il a
été incroyable à la à la récupération du
ballon toujours très intéressant pour
pour se projeter vers l'avant donc je le
mettrai la note de 7,5
7 j'ai trouvé son activité très
intéressante il a aidé à ratisser les
ballons au milieu de terrain on a
beaucoup souffert au milieu de terrain
sans secteur que dans lequel les Anglais
nous ont bien dominé surtout en début de
seconde période et ça a été un des seuls
à sur nager à un moment donné ouais une
statistique regardez elle apparaît 60%
sur 5 demi-finales jouées en Coupe du
monde la France atteint trois fois le
stade de la finale alors attendez je
crois qu'elle est pas bonne cette stats
on n'a pas joué 6 demi-finales
alors je crois qu'ils n'ont pas pris en
compte cette année justement l'année
86 98 2006 2018 alors on en a joué 6
c'est ça ouais ils ont oublié 1958 voilà
c'est ça donc attention on va revérifier
ce chiffre c'est bien la 7e de
demi-finale des bleus et on va contrôler
tout ça évidemment ou réagissez sur
YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr on continue de
noter les Bleus tout le monde a noté
j'ai pas noté allez-y Vincent
je trouve que ouais il a fait un bon
match dans l'ensemble et au milieu de
terrain on a quand même été en grande
difficulté en deuxième période et mine
de rien il est aux côtés même s'il fait
quelques en fait ils ont été plutôt bons
offensivement et puis pas terrible
défensivement
donc 7 je trouve que c'est cher payé
quoi allez Antoine Griezmann
Antoine Griezman Vincent roserand vous
lui donneriez combien il a été lui au
contraire très défensif et pas forcément
efficace offensivement non
alors première mi-temps il a été
excellent après il est un peu il a moins
vu offensivement en fait mais en
première mi-temps il était assez
impressionnant offensivement quand même
à bien orienter le jeu de façon
magnifique ouais moi je mettrai un si
c'est demi alors on doit Griezmann
c'est la note qu'on donnait nos amis du
Figaro est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça si cette nuit tous ouais plutôt
d'accord on passe alors Ousmane Dembélé
tiens est-ce que c'est pas lui le joueur
le moins en vue de ce match finalement
vous vous avez massacré je le kundai
pour le plaisir mais quand tu aimes pas
mais le couloir droit encore une fois se
faire comme contre la Pologne en fait ça
a été le même match je trouve des deux
Dembélé encore une fois enfin j'ai pas
compris ce qu'il faisait avec ses jambes
en fait j'ai l'impression que
généralement il court
les gens vont plus vite que son cerveau
c'est un peu ça voilà c'est un peu ça et
j'ai trouvé qu'il était encore une fois
brouillon comme comme le dernier match
ouais c'est vrai qu'il a été bon presque
pendant un quart d'heure et puis après
ça c'est un peu alors vous lui donnez
combien 4 et vous quatre
dans le stade Olivier Giroud le buteur
peut-être l'homme du match finalement
grâce à son but combien c'est 6 avec un
but comme ça en quart de finale de Coupe
du Monde
très important il a été utile je trouve
qu'il a gagné les duels surtout en fin
de match parce que longtemps on a on a
allongé le jeu pour pour le trouver et
gagner pas les duels et c'est vrai qu'il
a été décevant là c'est ton boulot là il
faut bien sûr
et le la sortie de Stone d'ailleurs la
la bien tranquillisé mais j'ai trouvé
qu'il est monté en puissance qui était
monté en puissance au fil de du match
bon on continue à aller avec
la star des bleus et qui viennent Mbappé
et il est passé à côté de son match je
m'appelle non
c'est standards sont tellement élevés
que effectivement on est obligé de dire
qu'il a plus ou moins raté son match
donc pour ma part je pense que je lui
mettrais 5
pour un match comme celui-là il avait
pas répondu aux attentes il a beaucoup
des données on l'a enfin il cherchait
beaucoup le ballon plus bas et j'ai
trouvé que il était très brouillon dans
ses choix voilà on a des images des
Champs-Élysées alors on va voir ce qui
se passe ce soir sur les champs parce
que avec la qualification du Maroc la
qualification des Bleus
situation à suivre sur les
Champs-Élysées évidemment on espère que
tout va bien se passer parce que c'est
quand même normalement une soirée de
fête Vincent roseron vous êtes toujours
devant le stade vous Killian Mbappé qui
est au plus près j'imagine que vous
l'avez regardé très attentivement quelle
note vous lui donnez et pourquoi
c'est compliqué en fait il est compliqué
à noter parce qu'il a été très très bien
serré forcément par quel Walker et les
gens qui et les autres joueurs anglais
qui faisaient l'aider pour moi je lui
mettrais à 5 quand même parce que il a
fait peser cette menace permanente qui a
permis d'ouvrir en fait les espaces sur
les autres côtés du terrain et il est un
peu impliqué sur le premier but aussi
donc voilà tu sens que ça me paraît pas
trop cher payé 5 c'est la note qu'on
donnait donc nos amis dans le stade tout
le monde a noté Mbappe Tanguy je vous ai
pas snober cette fois bon voilà pour les
chacun son tour Vincent c'est vrai
donnez-moi votre avis moi je lui
mettrais pas la moyenne non plus je lui
mettrais 4 et demi parce que finalement
il a pas fait de différence on l'a pas
vu beaucoup dans cette rencontre alors
que c'était l'homme du match tous les
Anglais n'ont parlé que lui nous aussi
on a parlé que de lui toute la semaine
et au final il est pas là bon il est pas
là mais il sera là en demi-finale quoi
qu'il arrive allez on continue et on se
projette parce qu'il y a donc un match
ça fait un moment qu'on a pas affronté
le Maroc vous savez
remonte le dernier match 2007 quelle
machine vous êtes bon moi regardez cette
statistique 2007 la France et le Maroc
vont s'affronter pour la première fois
depuis 15 ans on peut voir le tableau
général aussi de cette coupe du monde
parce qu'on a deux demi-finales
surprises alors de l'autre côté
finalement les crottes une surprise que
ça finalement ça a déjà une équipe qui à
jour ou l'autre méritera de la gagner
cette coupe du monde peut-être parce
qu'à force d'enchaîner les demi-finales
et peut-être les finales et bien elle y
arrivera et de l'autre côté donc France
- Maroc c'est incroyable demi-finale et
on a presque envie de se dire mais
quelle chance quoi franchement oui bah
c'est une opposition une opposition de
style on peut dire même si voilà le
Maroc enfin j'ai l'impression que le
Maroc joue de la même manière que la que
la France aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
rencontrer voilà en contre
se repose sur une une grosse solidarité
en défense
0-0 contre la croix c'est un autre demi
finaliste ils ont battu la Belgique ils
ont battu le Canada en encaissant un
seul but qui qualification contre
l'Espagne au tir au but et qualification
contre le Portugal donc avec ce but de
la tête tout à l'heure avec tout ça je
pense que le match va pas faire la
demi-finale premier d'être soporifique
qui jouent pas voilà mais bon on verra
mais au final avec peut-être des espaces
et un Maroc j'ai l'impression Vincent
qui va arriver très fatigué non bah
physiquement là ils ont beaucoup ils
avaient déjà beaucoup donné contre
l'Espagne là ça a été encore plus
compliqué face au Portugal ils ont fait
que défendre et physiquement plus il y a
des jours qui commencent à être blessés
commencent à tirer la langue ouais j'ai
peur que ça explose moi face aux
Français en demi-finale carrément
explosé non non mais moi je j'ai hâte de
voir comment on va se comporter est-ce
que le fait que la France risque de
prendre le jeu à son compte est-ce que
ça va être bien géré ou pas par les
Bleus vous avez vu contre la Pologne on
a quand même réussi à leur laisser le
ballon oui c'est vrai mais de toute
façon l'idée des champs n'aiment pas
tellement la possession mais il dit à
tout le monde qui veut la possession et
puis on l'a jamais non mais on aime bien
laisser les clés du jeu aux adversaires
mais effectivement c'est une pour le
coup c'est même pas une opposition de
style c'est carrément si c'était deux
même styles qui vont être face à face
donc voilà et je voulais rajouter un
petit un petit élément par rapport à la
Croatie vous disiez que très bien de la
gagner cette coupe du monde peut-être ça
serait mieux cette année parce que les
vieux briscard Modric les péricides etc
ils commencent à prendre de l'âge même
s'il rayonne
quelle est l'équipe la plus grande
nation en avoir du foot à n'avoir jamais
gagné la Coupe du monde
et qui peut-être
Vincent qui qui devrait un jour la
gagner de la part encore la petite
étoile là sur le logo
moi je pense que c'est les Pays-Bas a
priori quand même par histoire foot du
pays je dirais le Pays-Bas il y a le
Portugal qui peut aussi jouer dans cette
catégorie là mais oui oui je veux devant
la croix surtout même si la Croatie
alors il faut quand même se rendre
compte avec le réservoir qu'ils ont le
nombre d'habitants de demi-finales en 4
ans il avait déjà fait demi-finale en 98
il faut quand même se rendre compte du
boulot du coach actuellement d'arriver à
amener deux fois cette équipe qui sait
ce qu'elle fait effectivement et c'est
un pays jeune en plus la Croatie
évidemment puisqu'ils ne sont
compétition que depuis à la Coupe du
Monde depuis 1998 évidemment bien sûr la
guerre dans dans ces pays évidemment on
revient on reparle du Maroc
disons quand même est-ce que ce que me
dit ça vient ils ont sorti des plus
grosses équipes que nous hein les Belges
les Portugais les Espagnols ça c'est pas
rien pardon excusez-moi mais c'est un
peu épouvantail sur le papier ça peut
faire peur quand on voit les
anniversaires parce qu'ils ont affronté
mais nous on vient quand même de sortir
l'Angleterre donc on peut quand même
bomber le torse et se dire on est
l'équipe de France championne du monde
en titre je joue le Maroc en demi-finale
ok on va pas s'emballer mais on est plus
fort que normalement sur le passé
5-0 il pense que
va exploser
oui mais vous savez comment ça marche
c'est vrai que c'est une équipe qui est
là il faut le dire brillante qui régale
tout le monde mais qui est un peu
ensurez-vous franchement oui oui
peut-être après encore une fois ils
auront rien à perdre effectivement ils
vont peut-être arriver à un stade
physique ou ça peut ça peut exploser
mais ils ont d'un autre côté des joueurs
comme je pense à brabantiri qui sont
assez exceptionnels donc c'est assez
difficile de de faire un petit pronostic
comme cela mais la France part
évidemment
ultra favorite on parle du pardon par le
physique du Maroc mais je trouve que le
physique de la France m'inquiète parce
que je trouve à chaque fin en 2018
justement
donner sur la durée du match et là
contre l'Angleterre j'ai vu des signes
de fatigue
c'est très simple je peux regarder sur
les notes les joueurs qui ont été
remplacés
il me semble que voilà c'est quand même
notre problème c'est qu'on a pas de
profondeur de vent Vincent roseron sur
place le Maroc est-ce que vous les avez
vu jouer d'ailleurs ce que c'est que
vous avez vu beaucoup de matchs est-ce
que vous avez eu la chance d'en voir un
est-ce qu'ils vont exploser ou nous
aussi physiquement on est un peu à court
alors je les ai pas vu au stade mais
j'en ai vu pas mal en tout cas à la télé
et par exemple l'Espagne on s'est dit
après le en fait après sa victoire
contre l'Espagne on s'est dit bah ils
vont pas y arriver à renouveler
l'exploit où était blessé à garder tes
blessés deux hommes de base du système
marocain et finalement voilà ils ont
ressorti ce truc là contre le Portugal
ils ont peut-être encore perdu romain
Saïs qui leur voilà le défenseur le
capitaine mais il leur reste
hakimiésièse qu'il faut une coupe du
monde incroyable et puis oui voilà à
Brabant ce qui fait aussi une coupe du
monde folle et en fait on pourrait se
dire que c'est une équipe qui veut pas
le ballon et qui du coup est pas très
technique mais je vous invite à regarder
quand même ce qu'ils ont fait contre le
Portugal en fin de match ça ressort les
ballons proprement pour des pour les
contre-attaques et si les attaquants
marocain parce que ils ont quand même un
vrai problème avec leurs attaquants
marocains même si elle n'est séries à
marquer un but il pourrait y avoir 2-0 à
la fin du match ils auront pas chez des
rats au prochain match qui s'est fait
expulsé à peine à être 10 minutes je
crois après être rentré en jeu pour deux
fautes assez assez débile donc voilà à
priori bah voilà on est favoris mais le
Maroc c'est il faut faire attention il
va falloir se se méfier parce que comme
vous l'avez dit alors tableau de chasse
ils ont déjà le la Belgique l'Espagne et
le Portugal avec la ration d'Adrien
rabiot après la rencontre on a
l'impression que même lorsqu'on est en
difficulté rien ne nous arriver ça c'est
très important oui c'est vrai que c'est
d'une certaine manière l'ADN de ces
bleus quoi on n'est pas vraiment inquiet
jamais même quand on est égalisé on dit
oh on va bien s'en sortir d'une manière
ou d'une autre quoi Mbappé va sortir du
chapeau non c'est pas Mbappé c'était
Giroud mais c'est un peu l'idée qu'on a
non c'est un peu
pardon c'est la pâte Didier Deschamps en
fait c'est vraiment il est vraiment le
l'homme au milieu de tout ça je sais pas
quel est son secret il faudrait qu'il
nous le dévoile mais
la chance
2018 c'est vraiment tous les ingrédients
qui
qui caractérise cette équipe de France
je lis quand même ce message de Mafalda
il va y avoir de l'ambiance du côté des
supporters français et marocains en
France regardez ces images sur les
Champs-Elysées notamment avec des forces
de l'ordre qui sont en place on sait que
ça peut être une soirée à risque c'est
vrai parfois lorsque il y a des
résultats comme ceux qu'on a pu voir
aujourd'hui des résultats surprenants
pour le Maroc des résultats qui ne sont
un peu moins pour la France qui
l'emporte donc dans ce quart de finale
contre l'Angleterre ça c'est intéressant
elle sort un peu du foot et on terminera
là-dessus je pense que toute la semaine
les politiques vont s'emmêler très
sérieusement là de ce match mercredi non
Teddy oui oui sans doute sans doute
après bon ça c'est pas notre problème on
va dire vous êtes journaliste sportif
ça va entourer ce match et je pense que
les Bleus en conférence de presse auront
des questions là-dessus Vincent roseron
je suis sûr que vous allez leur poser
des questions sur sur l'ambiance autour
du match France - Maroc
alors oui clairement il va y avoir des
questions sur ça comme il y en a eu
quand il y a eu Espagne Maroc aussi
Belgique Maroc aussi quand même puisque
c'est c'est des affiches un peu
similaires on va dire donc oui oui
forcément il y aura des questions pour
ça et bah vous les suivrez je pense que
normalement vu que l'équipe de France je
vous mercredi ça va finalement arriver
très vite demain nouvelle conférence de
presse lundi conférence de presse et
mardi déjà vaille de match merci
beaucoup Vincent tiens je vous donne la
parole une dernière fois est-ce que vous
savez qui sera là demain est-ce que
Mbappe viendra enfin en conférence de
presse il va continuer à se préserver
alors je veux pas je n'ai pas
d'informations sur qui va venir demain
et je ne veux pas dire que Mbappe ne
viendra pas mais on va dire que c'est
assez peu probable jusque là puisqu'il
n'est toujours pas venu on rappelle tous
les joueurs de l'équipe de France sont
venus en conférence de presse il y a
deux conférences il y a deux joueurs qui
viennent en conférence de presse tous
les jours sauf jour de match et jour de
veille de match donc deux joueurs et là
on a déjà fait le tour il y a même une
petite question à Adrien rabiot qui est
à qui on a dit qu'il passe qu'il avait
une meilleure relation avec les médias
il a dit bah ouais mais je suis obligé
de venir vous voir moi c'est pas comme
certains donc petit tac là sont
coéquipiers Kylian Mbappé qui est
toujours exempté de media intéressant ça
j'avais pas vu passer cette cette
affaire et oui Olivier Giroud est venu
deux fois par exemple même dit Stéphane
il est allé allez dernière question les
amis est-ce que les Bleus peuvent c'est
le risque faire preuve de suffisance en
disant on est favoris
je pense pas parce que encore une fois
c'est toujours l'esprit de 2018 le
mental prime là on l'a vu encore
aujourd'hui on plie mais on ne rompa tel
un roseau donc non je pense pas cette
expression
mais non non franchement à partir du
moment où on est en demi-finale je pense
que peu importe l'adversaire il faut
gagner il faut appliquer la tactique du
coach donc je pense pas que les joueurs
là on est en demi-finale on n'a pas
besoin de leur dire les gars
je pense qu'on peut compter sur Didier
Deschamps pour éviter ce genre de choses
quoi il est là pour pour la gagne et on
va pas prendre le Maroc à la légère
l'éternel pessimiste
à leur place mais dans toutes nos
campagnes à chaque fois les demi-finales
ont été les matchs les plus compliqués
voilà je me rappelle de la Belgique la
Croatie en 98 le Portugal en 2006 a
toujours été des matchs très compliqué
parce que c'est la marge d'avant la
finale donc les équipes seront tendues
et j'attends avec impatient notamment le
duel entre Mbappé et Hakimi les deux
meilleurs amis ils se rendent du même
côté
a été bon finalement mais Akimi c'est
quand même la top niveau quoi
effectivement moins impression de quoi
le cœur donc elle m'a appelé ses chances
et puis il le connaît bien donc bon on
espère que Varane dansera de la même
manière comme Titi face à la Belgique il
y a 4 ans oui on a toujours pas eu de
défenseurs pour l'instant
toujours pas non c'était annoncé en
début de début d'émission mais non c'est
vrai j'avais parlé de deux
Vincent roseron je vous relâche merci
beaucoup reposez-vous bien vous ne
faites vivre ces trois jours depuis le
Qatar sur Le Figaro.fr merci d'avoir été
avec nous parce que vous vous aimez ce
que vous vivez en ce moment non et vous
allez assister à une demi-finale
demi-finale de Coupe du monde quand même
bien sûr
et oui c'était pas rien quand même on
mesure la chanson
je vous avoue merci beaucoup merci
Tanguy soyez des réseaux sociaux merci
d'avoir été avec nous Vincent Duchêne du
Figaro
Teddy vadevalu le liver du Figaro sport
ou le suivre sur tous les matchs merci à
Becker qui était en régie Julien Leclerc
qui assure toute cette petite
statistique qui arrive merci à Sylvain
châtelain la direction du Figaro live
merci beaucoup excellente soirée on se
retrouve évidemment mercredi parce que
mercredi il y a match il y a une
demi-finale de Coupe du Monde salut